foreign
Tampa Florida hey Ed welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey gentlemen how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so I got a real estate question
um I am 26 my wife's 26 and we are about
to purchase our first home awesome to
purchase our first home that is
um and got pre-approved recently and I'm
struggling with understanding what what
to do here so uh they I was quoted for
putting 20 down on a home and 15 down on
a home
and on a 15-year fixed and my rate for
20 down is higher than my rate
if I put 15 down that makes no sense and
I don't I agree and that's what I'm
trying to figure out why that would be
and which direction I should go you
should talk to Churchill Mortgage and
get a quote and then ask them if they
give you the same thing that's uh why in
the flip is this because I I know of no
logical reason that should occur
as a matter of fact when you put 20
annointment are you dealing with an FHA
loan or a conventional loan
conventional okay with 20 down you will
avoid PMI private mortgage insurance
which will amount to about uh three
quarters of a point I mean it'll amount
to a lot
right it's about seventy five dollars
per hundred thousand borrowed per month
yep and um
and so not having that with twenty
percent down is a substantial savings
I mean it's like 200 bucks a month if
you're borrowing 300 Grand
and the rate should be the interest rate
should be exactly the same either way
but putting less down would normally
cause you to have a higher interest rate
because it is a higher risk for the
mortgage company that's
that's what that's what I would have
thought yeah and they said that
the the lender that that I was so were
the new developed new community being
developed so it's the preferred lender
of the Builder oh whoopee
I prefer not to use this lender yeah
so there's not the preferred lender of
the buyer on the same boat yeah no
kidding
yeah I think I don't I I don't know what
they're doing I honestly have no idea
did they they give you no logical
explanation for the higher rate
uh basically what she said is that when
someone puts 20 down and the bank is no
longer charging them PMI they still view
that as a higher risk than if someone
put 15 down and they do charge them PMI
well that's just not true
okay because the whole purpose of the
the reason PMI is there when you put
less down is because it's higher risk
that's why they make you get it
private mortgage insurance pays the bank
if they lose money in the event they
have to foreclose on you it does not
insure you in any way it ensures them
against you
getting foreclosed on them losing money
that's what PMI does there is no PMI at
20 down and the reason is industry
standard is is the very unlikely to lose
money so Ed I'm going to ask Dave a
question is it Dave is there a
possibility that
because I think there's a profit motive
here that's what it is right so is there
a possibility that or actually at risk
that when you're over 20 and you ask for
your PMI by law they've got to take it
off but then they no longer are insured
against that loan they don't they do not
have insurance without PMI on a
conventional loan there's no insurance
so it sounds like this mortgage company
is saying we don't want to do loans that
aren't insured no that because they're
selling the stinking loan it's a Fannie
Mae loan it's it's all it's going to be
bundled up anyway yeah they're going to
be bundled up and sold on the secondary
market so they're it's a it's weird man
yeah it's a con it's a conforming loan
it conforms to a set of guidelines so
that it can be bundled and sold and so I
I think it's a local mortgage company
that thinks he's got a fish in a barrel
because you're buying this on a new site
and and they're the preferred lender
okay I prefer not to get overcharged so
I'm going to prefer to use somebody else
check Churchill and see if you can find
out what's going on there may be
something I don't know here but I don't
think so I mean I've been doing real
estate for 40 years so
um this is weird it's very weird uh yeah
and if you have the 20 down I would put
the 20 down rather than pay the extra
200 a month per 300 000 borrowed for PMI
that gives you absolutely zero benefit
so uh that's why we suggest 20 down on a
first time home buyer we lighten up and
go oh if you want to do 5 or 10 or 15
that's okay because it gets you into the
house but the downside is you're going
to be biting the bullet on that PMI but
I mean that's a lot of money so it makes
no sense at all Scott um I mean you're
you're I mean Ed I'm sorry you're you're
you're asking the right questions and uh
the best way to to do to keep people
honest is get another bid so go to
Churchill Mortgage talk to them and um
they can take care of you in Tampa for
sure they've been an Advertiser with us
for 30 years and uh that team Mike
Hardwick and that team do a great job
hey man thank you for calling in I wish
it was easy but it's good I wish I knew
the answer I don't I don't I don't but I
agree with you on the frustration I
think you're getting the run around some
way or another but maybe there is
something I don't don't know keep keep
pushing till you learn